Let's get back for the phones at (617) 830-4750
a lot going on this week and a lot of [inaudible]
people who want to chime in. Let's go next
to our caller from the three one three area
code three one three. What's your name? Where
are you calling from today?
Hey, yeah, this is Adam from Michigan.
Hey Adam. What's up?
Yeah. So, um, I'm not really a like a Democrat,
but, um, I look from other policies. Um, but
one of like, one thing I really don't like
is I guess in both parties, nobody talks about
reducing taxes. And
I told them, did you see, I just want to make
sure, did you say nobody talks about reducing
the Texas, the state of or taxes,
taxes? Acts is like, yeah, please.
Oh, I think both parties talk about reducing
taxes just for different, different groups
of people typically.
Well, okay, so I'll say, I mean like Texas,
um, they talk about the rich, but like when
it comes to, um, like the middle class, you
know, there is, um, even with Trump, like
his text on it didn't change much. So, um,
cause like, um, yeah, so like, um, uh, like
the uh, like they talk about like benefits
and stuff like that. But you know, like the
average person, if an American like 60 K,
they're going to be paying 'em like state,
federal, local, um, could be like 15 kid in
Texas. And if you include like stuff like
[inaudible] year, you're paying like 20 kids.
So I see, I see that it's like a, um, you
know, like just any like basic budget and
you know, you got to reduce your costs. And
like I see Texas just one big hospital and
nobody's really talking about, uh, reducing
tax.
So hold on. So, so listen, first of all, everybody's
talking about reducing taxes. The battle is
over. Who are you going to reduce them for?
Now, what you have to understand is that if
you're running for president, all you can
do is deal with this at the federal level,
right? The federal tax brackets separate from
that. Some States have a state income tax
and some don't. There are cities that have
city income taxes in the United States. There
are other ways that taxes are collected. There
are sales taxes, there are excise taxes on
vehicles, property taxes, uh, often places
that have no state income tax, have a higher
property tax. But that's decided either by
States or municipalities or the secretary
of state. So these are all different things.
But I, I think I take issue with your original
premise. Republicans talk about lowering taxes.
Democrats talk about lowering taxes. Typically,
you know, they both want to make it seem as
though they're going to lower them on the
middle-class Republicans tend to lower taxes
on the very rich, but everybody's talking
about taxes all the time. My friend.
No, but I mean like, it's like, so like, I
guess what I'm trying to say is like, they're
not saying all right, like, okay, like we're
going to reduce your, like we're going to
make it like, um, cause he was like, here's
what I want. You know what I want them to
kind of see. It's like, all right, if you
make, if you make under 50 K, you know, you
don't pay you like any taxes. They, nobody's
like really said that.
Well, no, because that wouldn't work. That
would be a crazy thing to say that, that,
that just mathematically it wouldn't work.
We wouldn't have roads. We wouldn't have police
departments. We wouldn't have firefighters.
Uh, we wouldn't have, uh, you know, center
for disease control. We wouldn't have a military.
Like, I mean, if just, if everybody making
under 50,000 pays zero taxes, we get rid of
a whole bunch of this stuff. We have nobody
saying it because it would never work.
Well, I mean that's, I guess that's like,
Mmm Mmm. Like, well, I guess what I want to
work is kind of like the whole point of the
democratic party is like the rich are going
to pay for it.
Yes. But when you, when you, when you look
at the tax base, um, if you say everybody
earning under $50,000 a year, pays no taxes
of any kind, you destroy both federal, state
and local budgets. And, and there's no question
that the very rich, we have a progressive
system in the United States, at least for
federal taxes, the very rich should be paying
more, uh, somebody like Bernie Sanders would
have the rich paying even more than they are.
But if you go to zero taxes for everyone at
50 K, you're decimating a whole bunch of different
budgets. If you're including all of the taxes
that you listed,
or are you maybe just, let's set it on, let,
let, let, let's just take the funnel. For
example. If you say maybe something like,
well, my point is you're going to need the
money to survive. So like if like, so this
is, this is how I see, I see it as like, like
it's, it's money being swapped. It's like,
you know, you give, um, because, um, the point
of Texas is, you know, it's for the wellbeing,
but you know, if you're already struggling
at 50 K like you're not going to be, you know,
you're going to be certainly in 50 K. so if
you, like right now, like if you're paying
like 50, 60, and he's going to be paying 20
kids, that's, that's a third of your budget
that's gone. So yeah, you might have a roads,
but guess what, you're not going to have a
car. You're not gonna, you know, you're not,
um, you're not going to benefit from any of
that stuff. So that's kind of, um,
yeah. So listen, I, I think where we can agree
is I am, I'm open to the idea of X of federally
exempting more income from taxation, but the
idea of zero taxes across the board for everybody,
50K and under, I don't think it would quite
work. Uh, but listen, I, I appreciate the
call. I'll give it more thought. I a, I'm
going to hear from a few other people, but
a very, very interesting idea. Let's go next
to our caller from the eight one four area
code. Who's calling today from eight one four.
Hey, this is Evan. Hey David. Not much. Um,
first of all, you're my favorite political
commentator on the internet or like, and,
and the, uh, really liked Watson, went on
the Rajoy. Yeah. Uh, so, so my question was,
um, it seems like the moderators really went
after Bernie last night. They made the cost
of attending $1,750. So obviously is the majority
of his base, had no way of going, um, particularly
in South, uh, South Carolina. Right. So, um,
I, I'm wondering what you think about this.
Does do you think this, um, concerted effort
from the DNC to suppress Bernie and go after
him actually helps him? As in if you think
they were burning neutral, do you think he'd
be in a worse position in the polls because
after the debate CDs, his own survey of audiences
asking them who did the best on the debate?
31 that, which, you know, I P it seems like
people are missing.
Is that, was that a, was that a website survey
or where was that survey?
Um, I'm not sure. I just saw it on YouTube
right after the, um, I
just saw the thumbnail. I didn't click on
the video. I don't want to get to CVS.
Yeah, I mean, listen, it's conceivable that
there's something to what you're saying that
by sort of going after Bernie, they are helping
him because people see that he's being attacked.
I guess we'll know after super Tuesday, right?
Super Tuesday is going to be a pretty decisive
day. There will be one of three outcomes at
super Tuesday. Either Bernie will do so well
that he will have a very clear path to 50%
plus one delegates. Either the results will
be so split that the most likely outcome will
be nobody gets to 50% plus one, but Bernie
has a plurality or Bernie will do so poorly
on super Tuesday that he won't even be on
a path to a plurality of the delegates. I
don't think that last one is likely. I think
one of the first two situations is likely
and we'll just have to wait and see because
we, we just have not had enough votes, votes
cast yet to know what the effect on Bernie
support has been so far from the, the corporate
media and DNC opposition to Bernie. But we're
only like five days from figuring that out.
Yeah. So I'm crossing my fingers.
All right. Thank you so much. I appreciate
the phone call. Great to hear from you and
uh, appreciate the kind words as well.